so here you see a classifier
that takes a look at this image and
assigns
one of many many labels actually one of
a hundred
and one labels as you can see here and
one of the labels is a photo
of guacamole a type of food and it
assigns
a really high probability to that as
opposed to like the the second
prediction which is
ceviche um so
you know classifier pretty good okay uh
take a look at this classifier
out of 397 labels it correctly
identifies that this
is a television studio um
you can go on right here and
so this is a photo of an airplane
whenever there's a green bar at the top
it means that
the respective classifier has this
correctly whenever there is an orange
bar
it's an incorrect label with the the
green bar being the correct
label so you can see here these
classifiers perform
sometimes pretty well on these examples
and sometimes
not but what you can distinctly see is
that these are all
from different data sets so different
tasks there is a
satellite image there is a car
and you're supposed to classify which
car it is not only
that it is a car so
very diverse set of of tasks and the
interesting thing is that this is all
the same
classifier so the this classifier is
it's not even fine tuned it is a
zero shot classifier that handles all of
these
different training data sets sorry not
training data sets
all of these different test data sets in
one go so that's already pretty cool
but what you may have noticed is that
the labels aren't
labels that you would usually see in a
classifier so
you know these these 101 labels here
they
are it says it here guacamole that's
the label interestingly the label the
classifier assigns is not just the word
it's
the a photo of guacamole a type of food
okay that's the label the classifier
assigns and the second highest label is
a photo of ceviche a type of food
it's not always a photo though it is
often a photo
but here you can see for example the
label that the classifier assigns is
a centered satellite photo of
permanent crop land where the
um the correct label here is the annual
cropland which is down here again the
label is longer
so there's something interesting going
on here
it's the same classifier it's zero shot
so that means the classifier is not
trained on these data sets it's not
trained to fulfill these tasks yet still
it seems to perform okay
and the labels are quite weird
so this is this is a
new paper by open ai which we're going
to look at today you can see it's a
pretty long paper but we'll cut it short
i promise
and it's called learning transferable
visual
modes from natural language supervision
and the model colloquially or also in
this paper is referred to as
clip so this is the model has been
released
along with the dahle model which you
know can do the
chair made of avocado and so on the
dolly model is a generative model that
generates images clip is a
more of a i don't want to say
discriminative model but
clip is a model that takes in images
and text and connects them in a
in a non-generative way so we're going
to see
what that entails it's by alec radford
and john woo
kim and others as i said of open ai
so the idea here is to connect text and
images and this has been done
in a in a number of ways previously even
in this way it has been done in one
fashion or another
i find the introduction and discussion
of lady related works in this paper to
be
very very thorough and and superb so
they do assign a lot of credit to people
who have had the various
ideas so the goal here is that
we want to get a model
that can represent images and text
really really well okay so
how do we connect images and text first
of all
what what if what if we have a data set
of images and text
okay so they construct a new data set
where there's an image
like something like this a cat and a
text a little piece of text to it like
my
my cute cat images
and text like this you'll find on you
know for example
social media you can scrape that
pinterest what not flickr people write
descriptions along with their
pictures so it's pretty easy to get
these
pairs of images and text from the
internet without having to
label them right so one motivation of
doing this kind of work is
if we train a image classifier model we
always need
labeled examples into you know into a
very predefined
set of classes so in imagenet we have a
thousand classes or
twenty two thousand respectively in
mnist we have ten
however if we could just somehow learn
uh to connect images with the text that
comes along
um we wouldn't be bound by the
classifier labels and we could get
very good representations so the
original
idea or one of the original idea is we
take the image and we predict
predict the text
from the image um of course dolly goes
the other way
so um dolly
some somehow goes the other way taking
the text and predicting the image
but the idea is if we can take an image
and from it
predict the text what we get out of it
is not only a model that can label
images but
what we hope to get out of it is this
process right here
may be very very good representer
so if this is like the image goes into a
neural network with a bunch of layers
and then out comes you know the text my
cat and so on then somewhere
in here in the intermediate
representation of the neural network
there must be a pretty pretty good
representation of what is in the image
so not not only you know the pixel
values
um but there must be actually some kind
of representation of
the concept of cat because otherwise it
could not predict
uh the word cat at the end okay so
the idea is to get a really good
representer
and then you could take that
representation and
fine-tune it to other tasks and so on so
that's
one of the ideas we're going to work off
here
and it turns out this is pretty useful
there have been papers before predicting
the um simply predicting the caption of
images
but it doesn't work too well so what
this model here is going for
and we're we'll simply um we'll simply
let's look at this graph right here so
they tried first
to predict the text and
you can see that zero shot and we're
going to
to look at what exactly zero shot image
net accuracy
means in this context but you can see
here that they had
some success with using a a transformer
language model to predict the text in
images
and evaluating that on on imagenet
however they seem to have more success
by using
just a bag of words predictions so what
that means is you you're not
trying to predict the exact words you're
simply trying
to predict which words occur in the
description so you see the photo
if you predict cat and my and cute
in you know any not non-ordered you're
already correct
and that already gives a sort of a
better efficiency
you can see the models here they tend to
go up
uh but it's questionable if that will
ever reach the orange line
and with their new objective with what
this paper suggests you can see right
here
the contrastive method
you get a way bigger performance
so we'll look at what this zero shot
accuracy means and why it might be
that these simply predicting the text
from an image
might not be a good enough idea
so let's say we have a model that can do
this
we have a model that can take an image
and it can predict
uh the the text that appears in it right
most of the time this model right here
is also going to give you something like
a probability okay like a likelihood so
if this is a
a transformer you can you can ask you
know for its logits and then you can
compute
the likelihood of a given label so if
you have such a model what you can do
is exactly what what
they allude to right here if
you have an image task right and you
have a
you have a model that can predict the
the text of an image you can take that
image
and you can run this sort of through
your image and through your encoding
pipeline
and then you can ask the model instead
of
you know predicting a text you can ask
the model how likely
is the text um dog
how likely is the text cat for this
image how likely is the text
mouse and then you can you get
some sort of likelihood right so maybe
it says
dog is this likely cat is this likely
mouse is this likely
and immediately you have built a
classifier so i hope you can see if
if i have a model that can predict how
likely a piece of text goes with an
image
i can by simply asking my model
for each of the for each of the classes
that are possible in the task
i immediately get a classifier out of
that i mean i'd have to normalize or
something
by that but i immediately get a
classifier
um and now you can also already see
why we might want to
phrase the things a bit so i don't want
to just put dog and cat right here even
though
those are the labels in that task right
if if i had an imagenet
classifier i would put here i would put
all of the
1000 possible classes and ask the model
for each
how likely is that label to go
with this image and the model you know
can produce text but the model can not
only produce you know the single word
dog
the model can also tell me how likely is
the phrase
a photo of a dog a
photo of a dog
or how likely is the phrase a photo
of a cat and so on right so
um and you can you can see that
this result here the classifier result
it might change actually depending on
how you phrase so here you can
use the exact same classes as you used
above
but by rephrasing the prompt so to say
you might get a better quality
classifier or a worse quality
classifier so if you already know that
your images are all photographs um
you will get a better accuracy because
simply you know the
the model if you you might get a better
accuracy by asking the model
hey how likely is the phrase a photo of
a dog
going with this image versus the phrase
a photo of a cat that might give you a
better
signal so less noise in whatever you get
as an output
than simply going with the single word
because again this model is trained to
predict this just from a data set scrape
from the internet so how often do people
you know post something i don't know an
instagram of their cat and simply
write cat with it whereas you know
maybe they they were right here's a
photo of my cat
right so the the phrase a photo of a cat
is
or they do like hashtag photo hashtag
cat or something like this
so that's why these classifiers at the
bottom
they were constructed from the labels of
the data set
but with a prompt that has been adapted
by humans
uh to work you know find to work
particularly well
on that data set so we're sort of back
to prompt engineering here
so this is how we go from a model that
can assess
predict text to
a classifier and that's a zero shot
classifier
we don't need to train this classifier
on the actual task we simply need to
restrict its possible outputs
to the classes at hand right um this is
a bit it's a bit like a tiny bit like
like you know in in queue learning in uh
where for in in each step you ask your
model
well what if i do action one and then
the model tells you what that's five
good probably that your q value is five
and then you just ask well what if i do
action two and then your the model says
well that's
seven good and so on so it's it's sort
of a similar concept
uh in except you know q learning we
usually train
end to end with an actual classifier
but i said simply predicting text
objective might not be good enough
right so we're going to retain this
property of being able to zero shot
classifier uh but we're going to now
switch out our task of how we get to
such a model
so instead of predicting text what does
clip do
clip does the following so what we're
going to do is we're going to take
the image right here and we're going to
pass it through an image encoder
and that gives us an image
representation so a
vector in some latent space
so this is image one and then image two
right here would be image two
here okay so we have a mini batch of
images and that's important
um then we're going to take the text
and feed it to the text encoder also
obtaining
a representation for the text right a
single vector
for this entire text right here and then
of course if we go to the second sample
in the mini
batch we get the second representation
and the batches of course in the
training data set we know that the first
the first text goes with the first image
the second text goes with the second
image the third text goes with the third
image because that's how we scraped it
from the internet and then what we ask
the model to do
is simply to tell us not so previously
we tried to predict from the image
the text right we went through the image
encoder and from this representation
here
we try to predict the text so we no
longer do that
what we're trying to do is simply ask
ask the model which
for so for this representation which of
these
texts is most appropriate
to that particular image okay
so this is why it's called a contrastive
objective
we know because this is training data we
of course know that image one goes with
description one
and image two goes with description two
but we're going to train this
in the way that you know we feed in this
image and we ask it
to which of all of these texts right
here
to which of all of these is this image
the closest
and we're going to train it such that it
is maximally close
to the correct one and minimally and far
away
from all the other so this this is why
it's contrastive it contrasts
what we know goes together right the
diagonal elements in this matrix
with what we know doesn't go together in
actually we don't know if a different
description wouldn't fit the same image
but we can
safely assume that a random piece of
text since we do the mini batches
randomly
a random piece of text will probably not
go
with this particular image at least not
as well
as the piece of text that we found it
with on the internet
okay so you get what you get is
effectively
for each input you get a classification
task in this direction you can see right
here for image three there is
one correct text that it goes with and
for
each text you get a classification task
in
this direction by the way this is simply
an inner product right here right you're
simply trying to
maximize the inner product of things
that go together and
minimize the inner product of things
that don't go together
so you you multiply the two for the
inner product you interpret that as a
logit
and then you do a soft max
classification in this
direction and the softmax classification
in this direction
so this is a symmetric loss from the
text and image perspective
and yeah so so it's a classification
problem
like a classification problem
viewed from two different angles so
you can immediately see that this relies
on having large enough mini batches
right so the larger your mini batch as
your mini batch size approximates the
entire
data set your representations are going
to be
more and more detailed right so
so you wanna so pepper the aussie pop
being close together to this particular
image means
that in the ideal case
it is close to this image and far away
from
anything else in in the data set and as
an approximation far away from anything
in this particular mini batch
and at inference time you do very much
what we did so far so you take if you
want to build an image classifier
and the interesting thing is you can
also build a text classifier right if
you have multiple images to go with a
text
then you uh you can do that
it's entirely symmetric but in this case
you take an image you put it through the
image encoder you get a representation
here
you get all the labels of your
classification tasks
right so this is the label is this
right here you engineer a prompt and
that you do as a human right this is
heuristic this you as a human
think aha okay i'm going to put whatever
this
is here you encode all of these labels
in their prompt context through the text
encoder you get the representations here
and you simply
ask to which of these labels
is it closest right so the is the inner
product the highest
and then and that's how you obtain the
label
zero training needed on the actual task
right so the data set that you do
this with can be an entirely different
data set
that then you do this with um
and this is extremely extremely uh
interesting
i've actually seen um some some
posts on on twitter and reddit where
people use this to guide a a style gan
to produce given pictures with given
descriptions and so on so
the possibilities for this are uh
pretty pretty huge okay so
that's uh that's the model the model it
encodes images and codes text it does
this contrastive objective what goes
together
what needs a part and now you see why
this might be
a better representer than for example
simply pre-training a model on an image
classification task
because if you pre-train a model on an
image classification
task it is going to simply lump together
every
all the dogs you know if this is if this
is your classification test it's going
to lump together all the dogs because
there's no need
to differentiate the individual dogs
from each other
right it's going to lump all of them
together
and forget that they are actually
different
right it's also going to forget
everything that
doesn't concern the immediate
classification problem
whereas this model here this model is
specific as as it gets better and better
it will pick up at more
of the text right so in in this case
maybe
if the model is pretty weak still it
will focus on this pup
and that's about the same as saying okay
it's a classifier of a dog
but then we can also aussie pop if it
incorporates that
if it gets better well it can
differentiate it from other dogs and by
the way it's a pop so it's a young dog
um it can also learn
eventually learn its actual name right
and and so on so you can see that as the
model gets stronger it can pick up more
and more
nuances of the data set so they
test this and they test it
fairly fairly fairly extensively um
and i don't think we'll have to go
through all of it for me to convince you
that this
is a good idea you're going to
maybe see it approximately or
immediately
so um
yes so they use different
different types of yes that's what i
wanted to say they use different types
of
encoders for the image encoder so for
the text encoder this is a transformer
so
transformer it's not a particularly big
transformer even
and they simply take the end of sentence
token the representation of that at the
end and that's their vector if you don't
know what a transformer is i've done
many many videos on transformers um
find one of them any of them
for the image encoder they test out a
bunch of different things
so they test out a bunch of variants of
resnet
i've done a video on that and they also
test out a bunch of
variants of the visual transformer the
the vit that has
recently been popularized
i've also made a video on that so
that's why their model shows up in sort
of different
uh flavors and sort of different
different points here they scale the
amount of data i believe with the model
so they scale everything together
compute data and model size and that's
why you see
different variants of the same model
they also
do ensembling so you know you have to
engineer
these prompts and um what you can do
is you can engineer better prompts and
that will gain performance
and you can also ensemble over prompts
and you can see right here
that that uh gets you both an efficiency
gain
if you want to stay at the same
performance and also
um sorry yeah and also it gives you
a performance improvement for the
same compute um with the same model
right so here the
corresponding dots are the same model
that's why they have the same compute
so that's just one of the fun things you
can do and again i think prompt
engineering will become
quite a bit more relevant so here
you can see you can see the comparison
zero shot clip um is competitive with a
fully supervised baseline right so the
baseline here isn't too good so it's
a fully supervised linear classifier
fitted on resnet 50 features on 16 data
sets including imagenet
so the resnet 50 is a popular
architecture it's not
nowhere near the absolute best we have
but it's a popular uh architecture so
this resonant 50
what it's what it has been trained on
is has been trained on imagenet right so
you get
so and that results in a neural network
with a bunch of layers
including a classification layer at the
end right into a thousand classes
so what you do is you pre-train this on
imagenet and then you simply take
this part right here up until the last
layer
and you take it so that's
this part right here and you assume that
this
has a sort of a good representational
power
since it can do imagenet and then you
simply
train a new linear classifier
on top that does the classification into
whatever new task you want so this is
called
um it's called linear probing so
linear probing you can also do it in the
middle uh sort of but
in this case they mean linear probing at
the second to last layer like before the
classification layer
so you assume that whatever this is is a
good representation function
you keep it constant and then you train
a linear probe
on top of it this is compared to
fine-tuning where you would fine-tune
the entire network
on your new task but they elect to do
most of their experiments with linear
probing
since it gives you a better indication
of the representational power of the
bases
so here they compare to image
net right so
on six and that is including image net
so for imagenet you would expect the
resnet50 to perform quite well because
it's been
its representational base has been
trained on imagenet
and training a linear classifier on top
it should simply give you back the
performance
that it had on imagenet here you can see
how
zero shot clip compares to linear probe
on resin at 50 right
zero shot clip compared to an actual
trained
thing not not the best but a trained
thing
and you can see that on many many many
data sets
clip out performs the resnet 50.
zero shot right um so no training
required beyond the pre-training that
being said the pre-training is huge
um but it's similar to gpt-3 right you
train it once
huge training but then you can do lots
of things
imagenet interestingly you see right
here only
it's actually improving imagenet
over resin at 50. crazy right
um whereas so resnet50 still better
in various uh other tasks so this is not
to say
that this is the new state of the art or
anything
except in stl 10 where it actually
appears to be
the new state of the art against all the
previously including all the supervised
whatever
it's the new state of the art on this
data set and the reason is
this stl 10 data set it has very few
training examples per class only so
supervised is very difficult transfer
learning is kind of difficult as i
understand it it's not
that similar to imagenet so that
transfer learning is kind of different
so this really seems to be
this zero shot clip objective seems to
be good
if you have um
images that are sort of natural uh that
happen a lot on the internet
but are not really like imagenet um
so there exists quite a number of those
and that you have
few labeled examples of if any
right so that's a that's a good
application domain
however on more specialized things they
say things like
you know tumor classification and so on
satellite
images this clip objective still does
pretty poorly
uh probably because you know that that's
not the type of
images you find on the internet with a
piece of text
super interesting mnist one of the
easiest tasks in deep learning
it also quite underperforms in this
in this thing so that
they do they do an analysis of these
different
data sets so they they compare to
resnet50 and also to
visual n grams right here and they
discuss
the the importance of the different data
sets
oh i find i found this too i found this
to be very interesting
uh most standard image classification
that data sets treat the information
naming or describing classes
which enables natural language based
zero shot transfer as an afterthought
uh the vast majority of data sets
annotate images with just a numeric id
of the label and contain a file mapping
these ids back to their names in english
some data sets such as flowers and the
gtsrb as it's a
german transport street sign or
data set i don't exactly know don't
appear to include this mapping at all
in their released versions preventing
zero shot transfer entirely
so what these authors had to do is they
had to like
look at the classes and then sort of
label them themselves because their
model works on language whereas this
street sign data set probably just came
with this is sign type one this is sign
type two they have a footnote here
alec learned much more about flower
species and german traffic signs over
the course of this project than he
originally anticipated
i love that i love a bit of humor in the
papers and
i so i made this meme um
where the street sign is specifically
tractors and trucks with an authorized
loaded weight
of more than 3.5 tons prohibited
i wonder actually how the model does on
exactly this
uh sign but yeah we'll find out
by the way the clip model is available
in
not the big one but a small one is
available actually
trained so you can test it out
and maybe we'll do a video on it where
we actually do
something with it so here you can see
that if they compare
their model to few shot linear probes
so here they compare zero shot clip with
few shot linear probes so before we
compare to linear probe which mean
means we just trained this linear
classifier but we did it on the whole
data set
okay so here we simulate
only having very few examples per class
which is where pre-training
really comes in and you can see
that zero shot clip outperforms
a lot of models if you only give them
very few
labeled examples per class in fact
it is comparative to a 16
it is comparative to a 16 label bit m so
this is one of the
best models that is currently in the
public
and that is doing this transfer learning
so if you transfer learn with a linear
probe again this is not fine tuning
with a linear probe on 16
samples per class with this model
you are still only as good as the zero
shot
no training at all of the clip model
that is pretty pretty interesting and
pretty cool
the other noteworthy thing is that if
you linearly probe the clip model
you way outperform the um
the largest models there
and also
what is also interesting is that
when you do labeled examples for clip
when you do linear probe on clip
the performance decreases first and only
increases once you get to like four
labeled examples per class
and that you know is um
is pretty intuitive when you think about
it so what you're doing is
so in clip the zero shot classifier is
actually a different one than the linear
classifier
so the zero shock classifier is in a way
already
trained so it has already trained this
sort of last layer
where as if you do linear probing you
throw that away you know
the whole part where you encode the text
and you blah blah blah you throw that
away
and you simply do the old school so the
linear probe here
this is no more of the is which text is
closed this is simply
i take this i throw away the last layer
i put in a new last layer and i do my
original classification task and of
course
this layer right here is initialized
randomly and it's going to require
some training and maybe you know one
example per class
isn't enough it's it's just going to
pick up on some spurious uh correlation
in the future
and it's going that's why it's getting
worse initially
but it recovers at four examples per
class and it severely outperforms the
other models
so we'll forgive it um
they do discover in various experiments
here
that it is very very different from data
set to
data set how this model performs zero
shot how it performs
versus linear probing they they find
that
um they find that very often
in in um in some
data sets uh that are far away
from sort of natural images they perform
worse in
again in some data sets they require
lots of
labels to match zero shot performance so
it is really a study
into sort of um
i want to say it's a study into what
kind of images appear on the internet
they do interestingly there is a trend
in machine learning that if you give
more data and compute
then your error goes down even with the
same type of models
and that seems to hold pretty well here
as you can see here
as they scale up this is the same this
is a resnet backbone
as you scale that up zero shot clip
performance scales smoothly as a
function of model compute
however they do note that there is a
whole bunch of
variations so the curve you're seeing is
the average
but for the individual tasks in their
task
data sets um
it it varies wildly so there's a lot of
noise here this could be because of how
the data sets are selected this could be
because of how the prompts are
engineered
there is still a lot unknown right here
they compare various other things like
linear probe linear pro performance of
clip models in comparison with
state-of-the-art computer vision models
and they do outperform all of these
other models as you can see here
so there is 12 data sets
in previous experiments but the 12 are
still sort of similar to imagenet
but if you include more data sets of
course that's sort of a
selection bias or whatnot but then
this model severely outperforms all of
the other models so the red models here
are
the red ones are the clip models
compared
to the other ones so
yeah this seems to be a step forward in
the sort of in the sort of
building classifiers for the average
user right
so i can now go ahead take this model
and
build my own classifier pretty pretty
easily
they also make some interesting
discoveries in terms of robustness
robustness to perturbations so
previously all these models they
sort of pre-trained on imagenet and so
on
and people have discovered that as soon
as you go away from imagenet
these the performance of these models
decreases heavily
so if for example imagenet v2 is just
imagenet
but is it they try to collect
i've made a video about that by the way
they try to collect imagenet
as closely as possible to the original
test set they try to
collect a new test set and immediately
the performance of all the classifiers
dropped in the light of this just
slightly data shifted data set
um and if you
if you sort of try to go away a little
bit further so you just have sketches of
these objects
um you sort of have this this
adversarial placement of
objects you can see right here uh it's
you know it's pretty it's pretty mean
but still a human
could do this right um
you see right here these are just
variations on the themes of imagenet
they have the same classes
so a classifier trained on imagenet
should be able
to also classify these images
right so here they compare zero shot
clip
to models that have been trained on
imagenet
and they find that zero shot clip
even though it matches so this zero shot
clip matches the performance of imagenet
by the way a huge achievement right this
is a fully trained model on imagenet
and this is a not the state of the art
but
respectable top one performance on
imagenet
and zero shot classifier matches that
performance
this is crazy okay uh you can see
as this classifier degrades degrades
degrades degrades degrades as you go to
harder and harder data sets that are all
technically imagenet images like in the
same classes
this classifier it sometimes even you
know
gets better but it you know it keeps up
its performance
which you can see here the difference uh
between it gets just
larger and larger so the clip is way
more robust
and of course this model right here is
trained
to predict these specific types of
images so it knows very well like how to
keep them apart
the only thing it has to do as a
classifier of imagenet
is keep apart the individual
instances of exactly those classes in
exactly this data set so it forgets
about everything else
right and as a result it he has never
seen a sketch
it it like a banana is yellow what are
you talking about
um so it heavily degrades right
and whereas clip it simply knows how to
sort of connect images to text so while
clip realizes that of course both are
described as banana it somehow has to
account for the fact that
there are also lemons in here right it
has to somehow represent that
um it has to represent that this is a
bunch of fruit
and that this is here maybe
a you know high-grade picture like
on a magazine where this here might be
more of a
sort of random gopro fallen into some
bunch of bananas
it has to somehow represent all of this
if it
you know performs well on its task and
thereby its representation will be
nuanced enough
such that it can transfer more easily it
picks up
on different features uh oh than
only distinguishing banana from you know
other classes in the imagenet data set
and that results
uh so here is the the curve in that if
you had the ideally robust model you'd
have
this right here so the exact same
performance on the natural
distortions than on imagenet
in the original imagenet
you can see that all of the standard
imagenet training
examples including all the robustness
techniques that
barely lift away from this curve are
massively outperformed by
a zero again a zero shot classifier
that hasn't even been trained on
imagenet and the fact that it hasn't
been trained on imagenet
might be one of the you know things that
it actually
is is very helpful so they do
they do some investigation into it
in including that you can in fact um
adapt to imagenet so you can in
uh i think that's the that's a linear
probe
if if you linear probe clip you can
improve the performance
on imagenet where interestingly
you can improve the performance on
imagenet
by doing a linear probe on top of clip
so this is logistic regression clip
while only mildly um degrading your
performance
on these other data sets so there seems
to be a value
to only to just having their
representation so their representation
itself seems to be more stable
okay so you can see as you adapt to
imagenet
this performance improves massively but
it only degrades a little bit
across the other data sets
so that means yeah as i said the
representation itself is more nuanced
such that even if you train a linear
classifier on pure classification you'll
still keep
up the performance on the other tasks
you can also adapt to class shift so by
better
prompt sort of prompt engineering for
some of these sub tasks but i think
that's a
sort of a minor thing
all right um yeah i don't want to go
you know too much they also compare to
humans which is very interesting
and they discover that you know samples
that are hard for
the clip model are also hard for the
human
model they do some sort of duplicate
detection from their training data set
because their training data set is 400
million images together with text
right so it's conceivable that there's
some duplicates but they find
even if there is there's generally not a
problem and they have like
a three or four page broader impact
section
as you can see right here which you know
is
um so if you read it
it reads sort of like um yeah there are
problems with these models we are better
than other models
but we're still not good enough or
things like this or
they always they're like yeah this is of
course we're better
like they're better at everything but
then again you know this is only
preliminary more study is needed and so
on
but i so they have some fairly um
interesting interesting results
so they what they do is since there is
such a focus on
prompt engineering right um it
actually matters what you give to the
model as possible labels so this is no
longer
fixed labels you can give any labels so
they have these data sets where you you
know
for example this fairface fairfax race
where you
try to categorize faces into different
uh
ethnic ethnicities or races um
these seven things that are given here
they also include some
non-human categories
or is it so they include they include
categories
such as here such as
animal chimpanzee gorilla or angutan and
they also
include sort of crime categories like
thief suspicious person criminal and
then they research how how the model mis
behaves and these models they do do a
fair bit
of you know kind of misclassification
right here as you
can see they also
so they notice that the
misclassification
is especially there for younger people
so these are the ages of people and here
are the misclassification
rates you can see the misclassifications
are
mostly for younger people then
they simply add a child category
and then the misclassification for young
people all of a sudden drops because the
model now has the option to classify
them as a child so this
i think the result of the paper and
especially of the broader impact section
one of the results is that it matters a
lot
how you engineer the prompts which is
something we already
knew but of course this can be
particularly
particularly crucial in some
applications
uh in some concerning applications
that's kind of
one of their points right here you can
see that the paper is huge and it
also has a huge appendix and they do as
i said a lot more experiments
right here um but all in all
this is a very very cool approach i feel
and it's as i said a step towards
making it easier for you know the
everyday person to build their own
classifier for
you know you can do quite niche tasks as
long as they're sort of natural images
this
will work fairly fairly well i think
it's
pretty cool it um gives
it gives a little bit of more freedom in
how you work with these models
and i'm excited for people to come up
with ideas of how to use this
how to connect this to other models such
as you can connect it
as we already saw with dali um you can
connect it with
stylegan as some people are doing i'm
sure you can connect it to
something like gpt3 and it's going to be
an exciting world
all right that was it for me thanks bye